wyoming republican liz cheney is a
member of the house armed services
committee and joins us now to discuss
good morning to you congresswoman cheney
this has been a disturbing turn of
events and we're all trying to process
it right now you look at the pictures
it's terrifying it's very frightening
what concerns you most as we sit here on
this monday morning
well it is of course uh just
catastrophic it didn't have to be this
way
and and what concerns me most going
forward from a national security
perspective is the extent to which
al qaeda
isis other terrorist organizations
now have an entire country that the
taliban controls we know 20 years ago
the taliban was hosting al qaeda while
they plan the attacks against us and
i also am very concerned about the
prisoners that have been released across
the country you've got prisoners that
were released not only that are likely
will get back into the battle for the
taliban and al qaeda and afghanistan but
will potentially populate terrorist
organizations globally so we've really
entered a very dangerous new phase now
in the war on terror
created an additional security situation
and danger that we simply didn't need to
create totally unnecessary yeah i've
heard you say that
i've heard you say it didn't have to be
this way there seems to be enough blame
to go around a lot of finger pointing
here in both directions
what do you think happened
well i think two things happened one in
the trump administration the agreement
that was negotiated secretary pompeo
negotiated
actually was a surrender agreement it
was a document that had a date certain
for our withdrawal it released again
guaranteed committed to prisoner
releases
and we were all told the american people
were told that the taliban was going to
renounce al qaeda of course that didn't
that didn't happen so we had d it did
not happen right so we had delegitimized
the afghan government cut them out
negotiated with the taliban a terrorist
organization signed an agreement with
them we never should have done that
but president biden never should have
withdrawn forces so i think ultimately
when you when you look at how we got to
this point certainly there is a
sufficient blame on both sides but this
decision to just fundamentally withdraw
really i mean we're watching unfold what
it looks like when america adopts a
policy of retreat when america adopts
policy of surrender it makes us less
safe and it's going to make the war
longer but congresswoman i think a lot
of americans would look at this and say
we made a 20-year investment in building
up the afghan army and they couldn't
hold the country for a month
are you saying that we should have a
permanent presence in afghanistan
you know what we need to do is is
determine whether or not and i believe
that that it is the case that our
security requires that we have
sufficient forces to work with the
afghans that we did to work with the
afghans air support
counter intelligence counterterrorism
efforts
to prevent the establishment of safe
havens if you look around the world if
you look at korea if you look at germany
there are places where we have troops
forward deployed and
2500 to 3500 forces on the ground
the insight that that gave us the
intelligence gathering capabilities it
gave us the counterterrorism
capabilities it gave us all of those
things were were you know we were able
to do those things under the previous
arrangement certainly that's been
completely and totally eliminated
secretary blinken congresswoman said
2500 troops wouldn't have been enough to
hold back the taliban
yeah well
it's true that the enemy gets a choice
but they were holding them back and and
our air power our forces on the ground
our intelligence efforts all of those
things
were working together now you know again
we had the agreement that was signed in
the trump administration that began this
process of helping to strengthen the
taliban we invited the taliban or we're
going to invite the taliban to camp
david
secretary pompeo met with a taliban
first u.s secretary of state to do that
so all of those things led to the moment
that that we find ourselves at but
ultimately this decision to completely
and totally withdraw is joe biden's and
uh and it is one that that is is
disgraceful it is happening on his watch
there's no question about that but i
keep thinking about the families who
have paid the ultimate sacrifice during
this
during this time period what is your
message to those families who are
sitting here wondering
what did we do this for
yeah it is it is heartbreaking i would
say first of all uh all of the the men
and the women who've been deployed to
afghanistan over the last 20 years
helped ensure that we didn't have any
further mass casualty attacks from
afghan territory they helped to keep us
safe they helped to prevent the kind of
attack we saw on 9 11. so their service
was really crucially important for our
security
and and i also think we need to go
forward
all of us who are elected officials
committing ourselves that we're going to
conduct ourselves in a way that is
worthy of their sacrifices conduct
ourselves in a way that is above
politics that looks at what the security
requirements of the nation are
and we need to have a very serious look
now at how we're going to in fact
conduct counterterrorism operations
around the world given the heightened
threat because of this complete
withdrawal from afghanistan all right
congresswoman cheney thank you so much
for your time a lot to think about today